les autres bah tu vas commencer on va te
faire une interview si vous deviez
mourir demain
jean-marie si vous deviez mourir demain
qu'est ce que vous voudriez absolument
faire ce soir
j'éviterai les trucs l'ont déjà les
genres demandait un renseignement à la
sncc y ait de perdre intervient à chaque
fois les frais non je crois que j'aurais
plutôt rester tranquille plutôt à la
maison plutôt avec des potes et avec ma
femme
je le dis très sérieux d'autant plus
qu'elle est bien placée puisqu'elle
travaille aux soins palliatifs comme tu
le sais d'eux un service de cancérologie
donc elle est bien rodée à aider les
gens à faire la dernière glissade et je
pense qu'il serait de bon conseil
je pense même qu'on pourrait même rigolé
real est assez
c'est assez forte mais c'est un travail
épuisant de face à tu t'attaches mais ce
que tu disais que tu vas mourir
enfin tout cas que les gens la prennent
ya d'abord la colère énorme de dire
pourquoi moi mais de quoi tu me parles
que tu vas aller chez le coiffeur tout à
l'heure et moi je les crever c'est ça la
première discussion
et puis quand l'acceptation est arrivé
les gens deviennent des êtres humains
extraordinaire tout d'un coup ils disent
non mais ne faites pas ça attendez je
vais le faire ou ne perdez pas de temps
avec sa ou moi ça va et devient humain
ils deviennent gentil n'ont pu toi rien
à perdre d'être un être humain parfait
si vous deviez mourir demain jean marie
vous relire y est calé livre je dirais
pas de livre impossible je mets un mois
et demi la celi que j'éviterai les trucs
leur ep et un non non non non je
préférerais être avec des potes boire
des canons dire comme tous les soirs
nos mines et ben voila tu viens de me
donner la réponse
je vis tous les jours en me disant que
c'était certainement le dernier jouet
très bien et quand je fais si tout le
monde faisait ça la vie ce qui est le
plus drôle et est en plus de toit avant
de mourir oui c'est ça que je choisir
j'essaierai de faire un peu mes paquets
de fermer alléger les valises plus
légers pourquoi pas partir plus vite
c'est à dire que peut-être que je
téléphonerai à mon pire ennemi ou à mes
pires ennemis et je redirai écoutez
franchement si c'est moi qui ai déconné
ben joue je vous pardonne et et toi
j'essaierai de faire au moins un truc
comme ça je me dirais même band et
garder une rancoeur et de partir avec
j'essayerai d'éliminer tous accords et
je pense que je partirai plus léger ça
ferait au moins plaisir
même au pire de miel nuit est ce que
vous seriez triste je serai un petit peu
triste d'abandonner mon corps ouais toi
parce que d'abord je lui ai fait subir
plein de trucs je les fais picoler et
tous les étés tout le temps d'accord
tout en gentil il n'a pas pu dormir ils
n'en voulaient pas le matin et voie est
donc vraiment je me ferais de la peine
de quitter ce corps kim kim kim a
rapporté parce que comme tu le sais on
meurt pas non et que l'âme donc
subsistent et après demain quand tu
arriveras au paradis ou un an
faire tu serais heureux de retrouver qui
tient il y en a qui sera très heureux de
retour et c'est ticky holgado way et mes
parents ouais ça très important je suis
trop content que je pars en ce moment
j'avais 20 ans toi tu te rends compte
que j'ai rien à dire gg
j'arriverai je dirais papa maman alors
sera d'être à caen mais ça le fait ou
pas vous avez vu le stade où les uva 6e
tellement fier il serait tellement fière
de moi j'étais qu'une merde quand il
sent quand ils ont disparu et vous
donneriez vos organes une fois cramer tu
veux dire ah oui c'est vrai avant de
faire cramer puis dans les organes oui
bien sûr oui ça c'est très très possible
quoi oui c'est ma plus qu'ils veulent
toute façon après moi je m'en fous le
reste ça va au feu ouais enfin je vaux
beauvais ce qui prendrait mais tu vois
si ou une oreille une belle oreilles toi
je donnerai pas le x sur lequel je
pourrai pas donné les yeux je suis
myopes presbytes maths etc oui on en
fait quoi
les courriels pendent de plus en plus
c'est lamentable
comme je mets des slips et qu' ils sont
toujours collés au plafond elles n'ont
pas le réflexe de s'accrocher mais comme
ce code est qu'elles sont et donc j'ai
c'est une catastrophe
je pouvais courir à poil pour moi je me
fous dans la gueule